eric thomas christe un bonjour bonjour
alors vous êtes candidat sur la première
circonscription celle du centre vous est
présenté par aka m ateke kilti matinik
qu'est ce qui motive votre candidature
alors ce qui motive notre candidature
c'est que aujourd'hui il y a trois
entités en martinique il ya le peuple et
à la caste des politiques et à la caste
de ceux qui pilotent les politiques
ces personnes là aujourd'hui on pensait
une martinique pour nous mais pas par
nous et encore moins avec nous nous
vivons aujourd'hui en martinique un
apartheid économique qui nous asphyxie
économiquement et socialement et
l'autorité elle est à 8 km
donc nous prends courage nous dit nous
qu'à décider nouqué goumain pourquoi
parce qu'en politique on a deux choix la
terre où l'argent quand vous choisissez
la terre vous choisissez les intérêts du
peuple quand vous choisissez l'argent
vous choisissez de défendre les intérêts
de ceux qui vous finance
nous avons choisi la terre la terre ça
veut dire quoi exactement
choisir la terre qu'on dit choisir la
terre qu'est ce que ça signifie
ça signifie la vie parce que la terre
c'est la vie le thème de notre commune
ces vingt collet matinik parce qu'en
fait quand on est en colère par rapport
à une certaine logique nous communique
aussi sur les quatre éléments de la vie
la terre qui a été empoisonné en
martinique dans le plus grand mépris
l'eau qui a subi ce même empoisonnement
et vous voyez bien c'est lavandin
gommier qui est sur la fiche pourquoi
parce que nous sommes des activités
nautiques avec nos enfants dans cette
eau là le feu parce que aujourd'hui
l'énergie
électrique il faut pas aller loin ah bah
costa rica il utilise plus de 90% hors
énergie qui provient du solaire et sait
pas faire en martinique publie pour
monter politique
d'accord vous dites que vous savez ce
que vous que est-ce que vous surfez sur
la
sur la présidentielle avec les derniers
résultats parce que van colen matinik sé
quoi faire donc c'est même pas on va pas
dire qu'on va sur festayres que
je pense qu'aux dernières élections il
ya eu un réveil et ce vent de colère
s'invente décolonisation qui souffle sur
toute la planète votez marine le pen
c'est un réveil suivante décolonisation
c'est un vote de sanction
j'ai entendu sur des réseaux sociaux une
femme qui a dit c'était qu'un chien mtq
a voté bailly d'accord donc c'est dans
cette logique là c'est un vote de
sanction il ya beaucoup de personnes qui
n'ont pas compris j'ai vu que dans
différents médias même internationaux il
essaye d'expliquer sa part des
psychologues possède quoi ma psychologie
du martiniquais d'abord essayé
comprendre qu outil yoka poison à nous
dans le plus grand silence et mépris
donc on est obligé d'être en colère non
c'est un vent de colère et qui aussi qui
s'ajoute qui s'adjoint un auvent de
décolonisation qui est en cours donc
aujourd'hui on doit nous respecter on
nous prend pour des idiots en martinique
ont vu un apartheid économique et
aujourd'hui vous voyez dans nos
différents thèmes le premier thème c'est
bien le non lieu contre le coloris comme
on va se lutter avec les moyens
puisqu'elle personnes qui me disent que
la politique ne peut pas fait sur la
justice c'est ce qui est écrit sur le
papier c'est ce qu'ils les lois des
navettes espace qui se passe il ya plein
d'exemples qui courent le deuxième point
en fait contre nous allons travailler
sur la problématique de
l'agroalimentaire parce qu'on peut pas
apporter 80 % de trappes et de
l'aimantation vérité ma partition
agricole c'est sa base et si la
diversification ainsi l'autonomie tout
dans l'alimentaire tout à fait c'est
largement possible main mont olivet en
les enterrant mental donc par rapport à
certaines terres de manosque en ce sens
elles mêmes meubles et pourtant en fait
quand on est en autonomie alimentaire
jusqu'à ce que je parte faire des études
donc c'est possible et en autonomie
alimentaire et vous voulez également que
soit appliquée la loi contre les
pratiques anticoncurrentielles qu'est ce
que ça veut dire parce qu'aujourd'hui un
dossier qui s'appelle l'abus de position
dominante qui existe en fait non c'est
simple yves jégo en a parlé en 2009 il
s'est fait virer par rapport à certains
lobbys mais il a dit clairement les
entier ont raison les antilles en raison
sur quoi il y a des lois aujourd'hui
contre les pratiques
anticoncurrentielles et l'abus de
position dominante elles ne sont pas
appliquées à maintenir la vie chère
j'entends beaucoup de candidats chercher
des excuses sur d'autres textes d'autres
lois des taxes sur la vie chère c'est
faux la vie est chère parce qu'il ya un
groupe il ya une caste qui a fixé des
prix
résolvez c'est pour ça que la vie chère
la preuve yuki tant pis tirs entraient
dans les télécommunications et qui ça
qui fait ni abonnement 9 90 sagement
donc ça fait au moins vingt ans qu'on a
perdu plus de dix mille euros si on
compte l'économie qu'on fait de 500
euros par an et ça je vous parle pas du
téléphone mobile imaginez sur la ligne
fixe inanition agroalimentaire local
temps pièce loto qui a coûté 33 euros au
cap et 300 euros je suis désolé c'est
pas les taxes il faut une vérité des
prix enlever tout ce qui est opaque
rendre voilà visible non c'est parce que
j'ai dit non c'est pas la question en
plus en plus il faut une vérité des prix
puisque effectivement les prix sur nadja
de taxes qu'on est dans un système
maintenant aujourd'hui l'abus de
position dominante fait que les prix
sont fixés très de façon très élevé mais
l'autre jour leclerc est venue quand ils
arrivent effectivement il n'a pas su
faire l'effort parce qu'il est pris au
piège de la même manière mais nous
qu'ils soutiendront piège talla alors
dernière question en 30 secondes
qu'avez vous à dire à la population pour
qu'elle puisse voter pour vous nous
avons choisi le peuple comme je vous ai
dit a deux possibilités c'est la terre
où l'argent qu'on vous présente en
politique nous vous présentons politique
nous avons choisi la terre donc le
peuple et sa descendance nouqué goumain
bat new look et goom un bas nous peuple
à électo masse crise pas merci je vous
remercie